à à
anh alo chào bạn
ừ ừ
ờ ờ
à à
Ê mày tâm tâm sự gì đã nhập
xe ga trước khi đi
anh vào bên trong nhà
cho tôi sẽ tâm sự mấy ngày trước trước
khi cho sang mày ôm cái máy này
ờ ờ
anh chị nó bảo là hôm trước thì tôi thấy
đấy
em có về có vẻ là ăn trộm xem cải cả
giải là do mà Mấy ông thấy khó nó qua
hay là do mình dậy chán hết Vâng đã khá
nhiều yếu tố
mà bé Hà Nội Hà Nội là to chưa ạ Alo ạ
bài hát nói to hơn chưa nhỉ
bé
alo alo alo nick này dạo này bị làm sao
ấy kiểu
áo kiểu dạng là kiểu nó phải rút ra cắm
lại
E73 to hết to cho tao rồi đúng không ạ
ở chung là tôi hơi lo vụ
mấy buổi gần đây thì lợn xem không cao
chắc à Chắc là tôi đang nghĩ thì chắc là
có thể do một có nhiều yếu tố đúng không
ạ Các bạn bận việc xong rồi Các bạn à
Hoặc là các bạn thấy khó nên kiểu
bỏ qua các thứ từ ga cái cái đấy tội
hướng đến không phải là đa số mọi việc
Những cái đấy nâng cao không một tí rồi
xin sau hơn một tí nóng ạ
nhưng mà nói chung là các bạn mà thấy có
vấn đề gì không ạ thì các bạn cứ góp ý
với mình như mình đã nói thẳng ra là kể
cả có 34 bạn học nữa thì mình sẽ dạy bởi
vì ở đây cái kênh kiểu mình sẽ để kéo về
sau luôn cho những bạn nào quan tâm thì
ông ạ
Ừ tôi vẫn cân nhắc mình việc là chị như
dại một lần trước khi mà có đông người
hiểu dạng hả Kiều
muốn tôi dậy tiếp hay tôi dậy lại cho
tôi sẽ xem xét sau A
à à cập Tết à đi cầm tiền lý do rồi nữa
mà còn đây này nghỉ à không như từ tuần
trước thì ra là nếu đã có tư tưởng của
Tết rồi thì chỉ hơi giờ
ừ ừ
Ừ ừ
thì cho ra thì
thì các bạn có thể đang chuẩn bị Tết tôi
được ra là
Ừ thôi con trai một phần là thế phần là
kiểu nhà tôi cũng không có gì nhiều
A và đôi khi mẹ thằng chơi theo kiểu là
bởi vì
có nhiều cái kiểu bị ngại chứ cứ thuê dừ
người lau dọn từ hay làm đủ mọi thứ
trong cũng thấy cũng khá là dài một hai
ba trăm nghìn Thế có nhiều mình đỡ phải
nói chung nhóm mà đôi nhưng có nhiều cái
thì mình nên tự là tôi Không khuyên được
việc à vì lười quá như thế nha mật đấy
thì không biết mấy ông thế nào nhưng
nhiều lúc tôi nghĩ thế hắn trẻ tôi sẽ
làm những thứ tôi giỏi kia anh hả
à Còn những cái thứ mà mình bắt buộc
phải động tay vào thì tôi mới lấy họ
dùng từ nhé Ở nghỉ để nó cho dễ hiểu hơn
thì nó Lan là giống như ở kiểu việc nhà
thôi cảm thấy thú vị lại và tôi thấy tôi
không do cái việc đấy tôi hậu đậu từ Thế
thì thì tôi sẽ không không không muốn
làm lắm mà tôi sẽ làm những thứ dơ giỏi
là sự đã làm cốt là kiếm tiền các thứ
xong rồi thuê giúp việc là
cho nên thuê giúp việc hơn là kiểu để
cho người yêu hay vợ mình làm hết
Ừ đấy thì à Nhưng nhưng còn những cái
việc ví dụ là sửa là về sau có con được
ạ thì tôi sẽ tự tay mình chăm chứ không
có thể cho
ai có thể kể cả ông bàn nữa cũng không
Mình mình nên tự mình trăn và mình tự
mình dậy thì thì ổn hơn đúng ạ phải lấy
quan điểm của tôi như thế
Cái này suy nghĩ không phải suy nghĩ là
lập trình viên nữa Tôi nghĩ ở đây suy
nghĩ mà tôi Tôi nghĩ là cho rằng nó khá
là thay đổi so với thôi trước thời trước
thì thứ nhất ở toàn bộ mọi việc thì
trong gia đình kìa thậm chí con gái là
không phải con trai bây giờ thì mình
đẳng hơn thì cảm chạy giúp đỡ bạn í a
con trai biến nội trợ chính Cơ nó sẽ với
việc nhà Bây giờ đôi khi là thế nhưng mà
còn tôi tôi nghĩa theo hướng khác là kẹo
nhé mà cả hai cùng bận kiếm tiền hay cả
hai đều đều kiểu dạng là Ừ ai cũng nấu
ăn không ngon này gì gì đó mình hoàn
toàn thể thuê người cũng được đấy chẳng
hạn thế
Ừ nhưng mà để vun đắp tổ ấm thì vẫn là
Linh cả hai gấu đây chăm con thì vẫn là
tự mình em ạ
anh không biết mình không có điện thế
nào
Ừ
thôi bàn tiếp về à cái thì à Không biết
mấy ông có lướt
YouTube nhiều như tôi gần đây không Tôi
lướt YouTube nó để Tik Tok Khánh đi học
thì tới khá hỏi chịu về cái việc à
Thằng YouTube đề xuất rất là chán
vậy Story Còn mấy kênh các thử mày video
thì có phải tương nổi Story không hiểu
Nó đọc sở thích của mình kiểu gì tôi
toàn thấy là nó ra mấy cái rồi video
đứng ra lượng lượng lượng tương tác ở
video cao đấy thật ra là nhưng mà ấn vào
bình luận thậm chứa nhiều người bảo Tại
sao ta được đề xuất kênh này ta chạm bao
nhiêu rồi cơ mà cái kiểu vân vân đấy
dù sao tôi cũng chặn mấy cách lấy tới
chặn sau đó em nó vẫn đề xuất kinh này
lên là kênh YouTube của tôi xong rồi tôi
có tôi không biết tôi từng nói mấy ông
kia là tôi từng nói là tôi có tài khoản
Google one cái Google one này là kiểu
dạng và ông khách hàng thân thiết cứ gửi
hiểu hiểu ở thế mất phí hàng tháng để mà
ông sẽ được những ưu đãi của nó là sử là
dung lượng cao hơn sau đó đi à an toàn
gì giờ vân vân nội dung có phải thêm vài
cái ưu đãi đấy Nhưng cái tôi từng nói
cái ngon nhất của bé có lãi thằng này đó
là mình thể nhắn tin trực tiếp với cho
hỗ trợ của nó Đôi khi em nhắn tin được
cho đội Dead của bên nó nhà phát triển
với nó bởi vì a kiểu tra lượng người
dùng khá là ít Đây là thành ra có thể
nhắn tin nói trực tiếp đến nhiều bằng
tiếng Anh nhá Đấy còn nếu mà ông muốn
nhắn nói tiếng Việt được gọng Có Nhưng
mà nhắn tiếng Việt thì nó sẽ trả lời qua
mail cho ông dư không có người trực anh
trực tiếp được thì tướng yêu tiếng Anh
thì mấy ông chưa biết tương đối Tôi chỉ
sợ hỏi mấy câu kiểu Hello Rồi sau đó gì
cả Ai H3 kẹo album hay hạ 2h và quá
trình đấy Kiểu thế Đấy xong rồi tôi có
nói nó với vụ vào kèo YouTube tại sao
đều thế như kiểu tao chặn cái kênh này
rồi nó cũng đề xuất Nhưng của tao thì
hàng ngày thằng kia nó trả lời đấy tính
năng
lần đầu tiên tôi ghét Google Thế mỗi khi
tôi rất thích hả Google mọi thứ luôn nó
đâu
Ừ nếu mà khi mà nó nó cái câu đấy thì tớ
chịu bởi vì chắc chắn đấy không phải là
tính năng thì mong chặn một cái gì đó
đâu lại hiển nhiên không mở muốn thấy
Nội xuất hiện nữa là nhưng yêu cũ vậy
đấy thế nên là không nói chuyện mà kiểu
chặn xong rồi nó sẽ vẫn còn đi rất nhưng
mình như Hưởng sao thấy còn quay ra bảo
tôi là kìa đấy chuyện chắc do Sở thích
của Mai nên nó mới đề rất như thế xử lý
của tôi giả vờ liên quan thì mấy nhà ấy
hiểu nhảm nhí như thế là thể đưa Story
của YouTube còn nhí hơn cả Tik Tok
nên là tôi thấy à giờ dậy I
ai ngờ tôi kiểu nhiều không thì sẽ bảo
là thế thì anh đừng có nước nữa nếu mà
cái đấy gì à chúng ta không nên chơi cù
gửi thế khi mà bàn vấn đề gì đấy
tôi đứng như là sẽ có nhiều cái mà mình
thấy ngứa mắt quá đấy nỗi mình bơ mày
không có tâm nữa Nhưng có những cái mặt
mình thường xuyên Mình dùng thì mình
nghĩ nó cần phải thả thiện và ta bia là
cái không khó bởi vì mình dân công nghệ
mình thấy là mấy cái không người khó để
làm chẳng qua là nó Nó kiểu đang coi nó
làm cái gì đó kiểu hình nhiên ra thế là
sai
Ừ đúng rồi mấy ông thấy khi mà chạm vào
cái gì đó Mà nó hiểu như vẫn hiển thị
lên của ông ông rồi thì khó chịu không
dùng nữa
anh không Không Ai Làm Thế
Ờ Ờ
nói chung nhà nội tôi tôi nói về cái đấy
để mà cũng rút kinh nghiệm về sau mấy
ông nên có
nhưng có đạo đức nghề nghiệp một tí
không nói câu tính năng kia đâu Hay
nó sai rồi cái đạo đức nghề nghiệp đây
nhờ Không ai có thể kiện được không cả
và đôi khi họ vẫn sẽ dùng như tôi thôi
nhưng mà khó chịu thì vẫn khó chịu không
ạ
ừ ừ
Ê mấy ông cũng mua sắm những người tương
lai lập trình viên màn không ạ một thành
viên vẫn là tương lai của Không phải cứ
cho của đất nước hay gì đó nhưng mà về
sau tôi tin à rất nhiều âm lập trình
viên phần cốt nhiều cái tệ mà kiểu dáng
hiện đại cục
Ừ tôi chưa biết kể ông ấy cái vụ việc áp
ủng của bên ngân hạnh thế Momo Anh ấy
rất nhiều này có nhiều này có vấn đề
tướng nghe tôi không nói sản phẩm của
tôi hoàn hảo là nó không Rồi một phía
giao diện rồi làm tệ lắm nhưng nhưng mà
sau khi mà
khi khi mà là một sản phẩm đấy Nếu không
đúng khi nói nghĩ theo cả tư cách của
khách hàng nữa xem khách hàng nhiều hãy
nghĩ gì khi mà dùng nó và khi một khách
hàng góp ý và Vân từng có kiểu nói kiểu
thuộc tính năng gì cả Tôi đang làm ở
công ty mà tôi cảm thấy rất là ổn là
điểm công ty tôi làm phố đắt nếu mà em
không biết công từng nghe qua về khái
niệm vô Đắc và Asus
Asus đúng nhá Đấy thì công ty gỗ đắt Mà
làm một sản phẩm thôi mà sống nhờ kiểu
kiếm mọi thứ lời lãi từ cái sản phẩm này
và gần như chỉ có 12 sản phẩm của công
ty hay giống kiểu Google thì nó sẽ làm
ra sản phẩm Google đúng không ạ xong rồi
nó sống sống chết rồi sản phẩm vậy thôi
Còn cái A sequel trứng gà để nó còn nhân
lực nhà béo không có ý tưởng gì cả bên
trong Chẳng nghĩ ra được cái sản phẩm
này thì thì bên bên khác nó kiểu toàn
thiếu nhân lực những người bên đông
người lá ông sẽ làm từ đầu đến cuối cho
sản phẩm sau mày gửi cho nó đến nghĩa là
ông sẽ thỉnh thoảng ông sẽ có vấn đề gì
nó sẽ lại ngờ lại ông để hôm sửa hai ông
nâng cấp thôi vân vân thế Đúng rồi làm
sản phẩm mình nó tâm huyết còn làm kiểu
này làm thuê làm công thì sẽ kịp nó hơi
hội thì tôi đang từ trước ngày tôi đều
làm công ty phố rác tự làm kiểu Tôi
thích làm một cái gì đó gần bò lâu dài
mình có tâm mình hiểu nó đứng nhận sẽ có
khó chịu có nhiều cái điểm tích cực và
tiêu cực riêng rất nhiều bài đã từng nói
qua vụ đấy Điển hình như là làm khô đắt
thì rất khó chịu được Giả sử Gần đây tôi
này tự nhiên sếp vừa bảo là ok Bắc này
từ cái mà cốt mà em đã làm từ năm tháng
trước ạ Lúc đấy rồi
ở cây váy hiểu mình lại quay lại làm lại
cái đấy Mình tưởng mình phát nó rồi mình
tưởng bị xong rồi nhưng mà không lại
thấy thiếu một năm trước không nhớ gì
Ông đã cốt 1 năm trước đâu đã đưa thế
nào xuống đôi khi nóng thế nhưng mà Áo
xù thì ông sẽ được trả tiền đấy con cái
này không
ờ ờ áo sẽ trả lương cao hơn á thuộc vào
ăn theo
cái dự án Đấy ông ông làm ông làm dự án
xong sớm thì không được ngồi chơi sớm
Xong rồi ông ăn ăn kiểu phần trăm hay gì
đó cả các dự án tao đúng đấy dựa đấy
toàn đã tiên cái kia thế Nói cho họ làm
hoa du học luôn nhanh giàu hơn còn làm
borax thì lương kiểu lương cố định sẽ
ngồi thỉnh thoảng được thưởng hay tăng
tăng lương Thôi đấy
à à
Ừ ừ thanh tìm kiếm thằng Facebook tại
lắp Nhờ anh anh thức anh tưởng có cái
video nói qua với cách tìm kiếm tìm kiếm
theo đúng đối tượng có vẻ phù hợp hơn
rồi Ở trên chính kênh của anh ấy các bạn
hệ xe và tìm kiếm dựa theo nguồn của một
người có kỳ hoa hôi trước là thời ra có
khoản diện tích để mà tìm kiếm ổn hơn
nhưng mà tiện thế như anh từng nó rồi
nên anh sẽ bị vỡ hơi cay
ở công ty sản phẩm và đương nhiên nó sẽ
bị gò bó bị Rập khuôn mà nó bị Hơi bị
nhàm chán đi làm đi làm lại một cái
nhưng mà nhưng mà đấy là mấy ông theo cả
là mấy ông thấy nhàm chán khi mà gạo xếp
dao đi giao lại một cái còn như tôi bảo
ấy Tôi đặt hết tâm mà nó nên tôi luôn
kiểu hướng đến nay ví dụ để hình bé ông
để ý nghĩa tôi luôn ghi lại một cái nốt
ở đây này tôi luôn hơn cái nốt là những
cái mà tôi thương ai vào xem lại cái
thời trang của tôi và xem và nghĩ lại
những cái thứ mình đã là cho tôi nghĩ
cái này hoàn toàn nên thay thế bằng cái
khác nâng nâng trải nghiệm người dùng
tốt hơn nó Vân bởi kiểu thế đấy thì tôi
luôn thỉnh thoảng thôi nghĩ đến rồi Thôi
lại nó lại rồi tôi lại làm cho nó ngon
hơn các thứ kèo tính tôi là hơi cầu toàn
hàng ra là cái này khá phù hợp với cả
hai mình vẫn vừa làm rồi còn cầu toàn
chỉnh chu lại một cái sân Phật một đứa
con tinh thần của mình ngoạn còn hơn và
làm kiểu Ý của bác hơi vô tâm một tí ông
làm kiểu tuần 23 tháng rồi ông rất nó ra
rồi đóng lại phải nhảy sang làm cái khác
thì ông sẽ bị hơi vô tâm tí cái kiểu
quên hàm ý đứa con tinh thần kia với Vân
đấy
Ừ ok Bây giờ thì à Còn Lý Phước thì mình
sẽ cho các bạn xem cái video của một
kênh mà cái người lâu lắm không đăng cái
ngày khá hay kênh Đu Đồ Đút nhưng mà
không biết được văn bản quyền không cho
không ở đây tôi thấy không có yêu cầu
nói kiểu bản Quyên cái gì cả
bài hát đơn thay thế và tránh về lung
tung chỗ bọn bản quyền bản quyền
à Còn nhà gốc và Chắc Ai Đó Sẽ Về cái
bài này hồi đấy đó tôi thường anh nghe
về khi mà tôi thất tình là bị có mấy hôm
chợ từng hỏi tôi
thất tình thì anh làm gì không ạ thất
tình thì tôi hồi đấy từ trước này đỉnh
thì tôi đến nhà chắc chắn buồn và kiểu
cách để mình quên đi cái buồn làm nhiều
thứ mình thích nóng lại Điệp Khúc Thì
Ngoài ra mình sẽ xem những cái kiểu nó
nó khiến cho mình suy nghĩ thoải mái hơn
về mối tình cảm nó Đó chính là cái kênh
đu đồ đút vào hồi trước còn đây vị và
mai nữa nhưng xavie xóa lịch sử vui rồi
như có kênh thác đang lên nhá có khác
mang lại rồi nhớ đấy nó cũng được nghe
cái bài cùng tôi rồi mày ông xem đã
anh bởi vì tôi nghĩ à Nhiều hôm đang
ngồi đây vẫn đang độc thân ấy là ngoại
xem thử nhé à
So
sánh thì chơi game
chưa thì xem phim
tôi lướt web đến khi ngủ quên
người yêu anh thì chưa có đêm một mình 5
có gió Bàn tay yếu ớt bắt sóc cho vào lọ
Những giọt nước mắt lăn dài trên mi cứ
thế anh biết phải làm sao
bạn bé xung quanh đều có anh Thi Toàn đi
friendzone tỏ tình bao phen nhưng toàn
làm anh trai
Ôi cô đơn quá tôi này cô đơn quá biết
bao đêm như đêm nay anh vẫn ngồi nghịch
1 Ừ anh chờ một người con gái Cũng có
thể một chàng trai cùng anh vui chơi
trong trăng suốt đêm nay đêm sáng mai
đêm nay chưa có chắc đêm mai sẽ có một
ai đó sẽ đến với anh và cầm đôi tay anh
Chắc ai đó sẽ sống rất hiện thôi Chắc ai
đó sẽ sống da mặt thôi cầm bàn tay trên
tay nước mắt rồi
chưa thấy đau
thôi kệ biết thế
Nói nhiều cũng thế cứ thế anh biết phải
làm sao
kể không ai yêu thì thôi Anh chỉ lo cây
tiền thôi tiền làm ra anh đêm một mình
anh tiêu
thế
nhưng sao trên khóc như góc phố anh qua
nỗi cô đơn theo anh đi đi mãi
từ nhà ra hồ Hoàn Kiếm nhìn xung quanh
toàn là khắp thì ra đi trên Đinh Tiên
Hoàng tử này từ nay anh sẽ quyết phấn
đấu trở thành đàn ông hình mẫu khiến các
em trời thêm
tôi chắc ai đó sẽ sau xuất hiện thôi
Chắc ai đó sẽ sớm làm thôi từ hôm nay
anh sẽ quyết tâm
hết fa
ừ ừ
[âm nhạc]
ẩm thựcthực à trong khi hỏi cũng nhắc
đến từ mình thực ra là tôi cũng khá
thích đó là nói tôi định nói
Ý tao là anh về FA
em nhắc chuyện với ba có khi tôi cho ông
xem nốt video nói về fa này
anh
FA thì làm gì ờ
Ừ hình như cái này không Hãy lắm
nó không phải hát thì phải có tại ba tin
nhắn gì đấy
a cho xe mày nghe bạn em bạn
3 nốt lộn lộn lộn
ở Tuy nhiên ý thì cái này hay cực người
không thay đổi góc nhìn cực
[âm nhạc]
về nhắn tin thì là một cái ngày lễ mà
các công ty thiệp nghĩ ra chỉ để làm cho
người ta cảm thấy như cả hơi nhất là với
những đứa như bạn những người tự gọi
mình Forever Alone hay là ế à tất cả
những cái danh từ thảm hại khác những
người mà cái ngày lễ tình nhân này phải
ngồi nhà thì chả có ai tạo cơ hội để làm
cái việc khác các bạn có thể là những
rite-size ngày chăm chỉ like và comment
trên Facebook của các tình yêu trong mơ
của các bạn và than thở là vì sao mình
không thể thoát khỏi friendzone hoặc bạn
cũng có thể là các cô nào tối ngày đọc
truyện người xem phim tình cảm Hàn Quốc
mơ mộng để rồi tự ti về bản thân coi
thường cái bọn nitrite Và đồng thời cũng
bị bọn họ còn tưởng có happily bạn thích
những người không có chút đoái Hoài đến
bạn Vì sao là có thể vì bạn không đủ tự
tin để tiếp cận mục tiêu mà bạn không
quen nói chung là bạn cảm thấy rằng bạn
không có cơ hội nào với tình yêu và chấp
nhận là An bài với việc đấy trước hết
thì mình xin chia buồn với các bạn là
các bạn xứng đáng với cái hoàn cảnh hiện
giờ nếu như các bạn suốt ngày than thở
và lăn tăn vì điều đấy Tuy nhiên ý thì
tin vui là để thay đổi hoàn cảnh đấy thì
rất là dễ dàng bạn chỉ cần thay đổi thái
độ của bạn đối với trạng thái độc thân
có thể là bạn cảm thấy lo lắng và tự ti
với cái tình trạng của mình một điều mà
rõ ràng nếu như bạn mới có mười mấy hai
mươi tuổi thôi thì hoàn toàn không đáng
khi mà bạn loại bỏ sự lo lắng vô căn cứ
này đi thì bạn sẽ thấy rằng độc thân là
cái trạng thái tuổi nhất chưa bạn độc
thân thì bạn hoàn toàn tự do bạn muốn
làm gì thì làm Thích đi đâu thì đi muốn
chơi với ai thì chơi với bạn đóng Đưa
với ai là việc của bạn và bạn luôn có
thời gian để theo đuổi bất cứ mục tiêu
nào của bạn muốn
anh làm cách nào để tận hưởng thầy chịu
đựng cái việc độc thân thì không phải
trải qua nhiều bước nhưng nói ngắn gọn
thì chỉ cần thay đổi thái độ bạn có thể
hoàn toàn biến mình từ forever alone trở
thành forever available con làm cụ thể
như thế nào vậy thì thôi để khi khác nói
mà khi đấy thì bạn sẽ thấy nào Valentine
chỉ là ngày mà cứ cặp đôi được công khai
ghen tị vì sự tự do của bạn và bạn nên
tranh thủ cái còn thời gian tự do đấy
khi còn có thể trước khi
khi mà mới kết thúc cuộc sống độc thân
thì nếu như bạn cần dùng tốt thì quãng
thời gian trước đấy thì bạn sẽ cảm thấy
có người yêu như là bị xích chân và cái
không còn nhiều thời gian mới các thói
quen cũ của bạn này thay vào đó thì bạn
tập cách quan tâm và nhận sự quan tâm từ
một người mới bạn sẽ không còn được tự
do làm tất cả những gì mà mình thích mà
luôn phải chú ý tới việc có ảnh hưởng
tới người kia hay các bạn sẽ để tạm gác
vô thời hạn việc theo đuổi mục tiêu lớn
lao của bạn để dành thời gian giải quyết
các vấn đề là mặt hàng ngày nói chung
với là khi tạm biệt cuộc sống độc thân
thì bạn cũng tạm biệt luôn của sự tự do
của bạn và rất có thể bạn sẽ tiếp tục
được nếm môi chữ được nhưng mà lần này
lại được đem lại Bởi chính cái sự xích
về chân bạn
bạn sẽ hiện ra là sợi xích ở trên bạn nó
chỉ là một sợi dây một rất là dễ Tháo và
cũng hơn rất là dễ Đức bạn hoàn toàn có
thể tháo ra và quay trở lại với sự tự do
của bạn bởi vì cái sợi dây đấy hóa ra
lại không có tác dụng ràng buộc mà thật
ra chỉ là sợi dây để dẫn bạn tới với
những cảm giác mà trước đây bạn chưa
từng được biết
cảm giác khi hai người chỉ nhìn nhau mà
không phải nói câu gì
khi vào bạn hiểu những bài tình ca mà bố
mẹ bạn thích nghe
khi bạn cảm thấy cuộc sống hàng ngày của
bạn còn tuyệt vời hơn cả trong mơ và khi
bạn muốn đàng phần đời còn lại cuộc đời
mình bên cạnh anh vào Bạn muốn phần lời
đấy tới càng nhanh càng tốt
độc thân là trạng thái tuyệt vời nhất
nhưng Cuộc gặp của tôi thì là cảm giác
tuyệt vời nhất
[âm nhạc]
cho đến một ngày người yêu bạn nói với
bạn
anh ơi hai vạch rồi
là sự thực thì bạn lại bị vô sinh
heo heo G2 cho mấy ông thương góc nhìn
mới về chuyện kiểu tình cảm cá từ thứ tư
a Garena Nếu tôi từng nói khi mình rảnh
quá
Ừ mình vẫn phải nghĩ nhiều chuyện tình
cảm nó ra khi mình bận quá ít đối khi
mình không thời gian rồi nghĩ nó đâu
Làm thế nào để hết Rảnh thôi Nhưng có
rất nhiều cái nó không ạ trước khi
nghĩnh việc là chuyện tình cao chứ khi
là kiểu ông kiểu ông có đầy đủ rồi nó
chỉ thiếu mỡ nó thì ông mới zz con này
việc mà ông thiếu đủ thứ cho ông nghĩ
rằng có nó sẽ bù đắp những thứ kia thì
chưa chắc vì tôi nói rồi đó là mấy ông
nên khiến nó Cuộc Sống Ông cảm thấy nó
hạnh phúc các sự thứ để cho để cho kiểu
người kia cảm thấy là mình muốn là một
phần em nó chứ không phải là của gió
hoang chẳng có cái gì cả Bây giờ tặng
nhá nhàm chán nên là mấy ông Nghĩa Kiếm
yêu rồi sẽ khiến nó cuộc sống của ông
bức ảnh nha Ừ nó cũng đúng Nhưng mà nó
là một sự thay đổi thì khiến cho anh từ
cái nhạt hàng cho không tải nhạc nó
ngoại
Cả nhà bây nhiên cần thay đổi không ạ
nhưng mà
anh nhiều người yêu thì ở không muốn
bước vào cuộc sống ở nhà của ông như tan
ra rồi kia ông sẽ khó lựa chọn người phù
hợp hơn với Vân Đồn
ờ ờ
cô bạn kia hỏi về cái thứ mà mình cũng
không biết luôn
lỗi vịt con đi à Cái thời gian đấy mà về
cho mình đường anh chán thôi Nhưng mà
mình nhớ không lầm mà mấy cái lỗi liên
quan đến việc cái đấy là quyền đấy thì
ông Ông này chạy họ tôi chỉ biết mỗi cái
cái cho kiểu chạy nó với quyền Admin Rồi
xem có chạy được không còn cụ thể hơn
thì cha ông trao Google thôi mà Có bạn
nào ở đây biết rành về đa cờ trả lời hổ
còn đấy tôi toàn cho Google cơ mà
Em ăn có được thì hỏi hỏi à ra tôi bảo
tôi công ty tôi thì có dùng đắp cơ nhưng
mà có anh cái hộ cho nên là cái toàn hoa
anh đấy nếu mà có vấn đề gì
anh hiểu cho tôi cũng chưa muốn tìm hiểu
Ở bên này lắm Nếu mình đi thôi cho anh
biết dùng cơ bản biết dùng thôi
Ừ Ok bây giờ thì tôi xin phép trả lời ờ
trả lời câu này trước đi tắt tường lửa
để chơi game không chưa Bạn gái tôi làm
cho này ờ
thì ra là các bạn không bao giờ nên tắt
tường lửa để làm cái gì đó giống như
kiểu các bạn à crack mà cái gì đó thì
các bạn lại tắt tự từng lừa đi để bảo
tắt Windows defender đi để tránh bị diệt
virus diệt luôn cả cái con crash nóng
hoặc nó ra Vân thật là không lên Bởi vì
thực ra là win 10 này khá là bảo mật hơn
so với các phiên bản Win trước đã biết
nó còn Thường xuyên cập nhật để mình
nâng cấp về các bạn mà thôi để mà tránh
bị hack Hùng Tráng bị ransomware Vân thì
mấy ông không nên kiểu dạng tắt nó đi Hà
tự bóp nó không ạ Mình không biết được
cái thôi Hồi chưa bị hai khủng nhiều như
lại nhiều như cơm bữa nha Đâu có tải bất
cứ gì về rằng dễ bị cộng đồng virus thử
bây giờ nó còn ghế hơn nó còn chơi không
phải virus nó làm xong web đây là nó mã
hóa tất cả file của ông thôi nó tốn tiền
không
ở tấm tiền cái kia ông phải trả tiền nó
nó thì nó mới dạy nó mới gửi cho cái mã
rồi giải không thì toàn bộ dữ liệu ông
gần nhau mất hết đấy thì
Anh nhớ là mấy ông lên tại những cái
trang uy tín Thứ Hai là nếu không nên
tắt máy cái gì đi nếu không có thể cho
nó vào là kiểu while its ra kiểu danh
sách ạ danh sách kiểu không không cần
duyệt mình sẽ tin cậy để để có thể chạy
được những cái đấy
số báo danh sách lại - với Windows
defender để mà kéo nếu mà đấy là chắc
chắn là khi mà con crack của ông ông
thấy thời gian nó không ấy gì ta chỗ
ngồi mới cho danh sách đấy và như tôi
vừa nói đó là mấy ông nên tại Black cũng
mê ở trang nào đó mà cảm thấy tí một tí
ở trang nào ý con béo hỏi tôi trang nào
Thế nào là uy tín đấy Ra đây đây tôi thử
ví dụ một cái Điền hình gần tới gần đây
tôi chai nhé comta
kia này
không hẳn là Trang từng tiếng Việt là
cái tin nhé Cũng không hoàn lại tra nước
ngoài cái gì nhé
Tôi thử cho Black này
các chuyên viên hay tỉa ngày cũng vậy
Mỹ Tâm Tâm tra được tinh tế kinh tế là
tôi nghị 50 50 backroom kinh tế 50 năm
Mưa Sa ngày trước là tôi không vào à này
nhìn Chồng nạp hoặc lúc kiến thức cũng
chưa ra nha phần mềm pro không học bằng
lái xe trông thấy cái kịch tiêu đề này
cái này nó lên tới cảo không tốt thủ
thuật cũng không những cái rất ít rồi
đấy không À music cái gì đó khi mực in
Tuấn Long khớp gái
à à
nghe tiếng nha à
ở góc chia sẻ đi cái còn cái nhóm đấy
đại chúa tể cái gì không
10 full crack không những cái cha mà có
crack thằng đấy chắc chắn là nó chỉ có
virus thôi không Ừ cái này tương tự đúng
không
Không biết cái nghề cái gì tới câu tôi
nói 5250 ngũ kiếm gì khác
cho laptop cũ xách tay + chuột
dù gì cũng khó
ờ ờ
anh hả
Ừ cái chúa tể là đi
các bạn chúa tể Hồng linh tinh à
ừ ừ
anh nói chung là tôi tôi đang nói trên
góc nhìn của tôi Tôi chưa thử mày cái
trang kia thôi không Tôi không thể khẳng
định được là nó uy tín thật đấy Không
nhưng mà tôi nói theo góc nhìn của tôi
thôi
a cho tôi sẽ thấy nó quen hay không Vân
tên của tên miền của nó có tư sếp này
cũng không này Không điều đấy nó không
sếp đâu đấy
ABC ABCD Online 0 Crack này không này
cung cấp phần mềm không này rất nhiều
khi không luôn
Nếu người Tày mấy cái này xem chuẩn bị
virus này
Ừ cái rồi đảm bảo được
ờ ờ
Ừ nó khóa sau có sau này cho là phải sau
bảo vệ được một sau tết cho tầm khoảng
ba đấy tháng 3 mình sẽ bắt đầu dậy pp mở
rộng nâng cao tí
Ừ nó nói chung là mấy ông cơ
vì mình không có thể chạy trước bằng Săn
boss nóng ạ tôi tôi nói rõ qua vụ
Windows Windows có phải săn bóp rồi mà
không mở hết mọi thứ trong đấy tại trong
đấy chạy thử xem thế nào mà Vân kiểm tra
xem mà có vị virus Cái thứ thứ không nói
trước khi kiểu chơi mấy cái câu Chrome
Mình là dân công nghệ rồi Ừ thì mình
không được dạy mà cái đến những chưa Ừ
mình cũng kiểu à cũng không học rồi mấy
cái đấy không ạ nhưng mà mình vẫn không
nên tránh để bị Hạnh Hùng Cái gì đó
nghèo kiểu sẽ sai bởi vì em mình dân
công nghệ thì mình phải biết cách tra
Google cái đấy cái tối thiểu mà em còn
phải biết là biết sao Google biết chọn
lọc thông tin nóng loạn thông tin trên
Google rất nhiều mình không nên chọn lọc
mày cũng không Cái gì cũng bấm mà cái gì
Click vào thì mới Ông không phải dân
công nghệ đổi trong mắt tôi mời ông chị
mày ông à gọi là có học về cái ngày này
chứ không phải chuyên về bên IP ở đây
chưa
tiếp theo bây giờ sẽ trả lời câu này một
câu khá hay cũng chưa Bạn có bạn hỏi cho
bạn từng nhập rồi và cái này tôi sẽ nói
là thử xem là sử là bạn đấy muốn làm như
thế này nó sẽ có khái niệm mà tay nút
từng ai dùng cái thư viện này rất là sao
ta xơ và bạn đấy muốn bạn muốn nhé đó là
kiểu xả sự sản phẩm bạn đấy thêm một thể
loại nào đó hoặc thậm chí là thường đấy
thể loại còn thằng lần thứ không hẳn
thêm nhiều đến thế Nhưng mà thường là có
thể là
các bạn bằng một bộ phim ở đó là sự các
bạn làm hoa cái trang web tin tức thì
các bạn là một bài tin tức nó có sẽ rất
nhiều cái tát có liên quan đến cái bài
đấy thì nó là khái niệm Tab input như
thế này và các bạn à và bạn ấy mua làm
Nó là kiểu dạng mà không phải là kiểu
sinh gạch ốp chân Nếu kiểu là cứ ngập
hết một đống thể loại trước có sẵn sau
đó đi gốc mà
từ lúc mà chọn sản phẩm thì nó liệt kê
ra mà sẽ làm đi cửa cứ nhập nhập nhập Nó
có thể gợi ý ra và hoàn toàn thế Mình
enter cái nó sẽ thêm một cái Và như thế
này đây để tôi thử làm cho mấy ông thể
hình dung ra nhá
Em có phải
Ừ cố ta Nếu không sẽ hình dung hơn
ừ ừ
à à
có thể loại sản phẩm tôi không có đúng
không
à mà không bây giờ đã
tạo hành bạn dư âm và một sản phẩm có
nhiều thể loại được thể loại tiếng Anh
là dễ thay à
Ô
hay nhỉ Ừ cái lò ra đi nó sẽ là chị hai
cục tặng gửi thế nó sẽ là mã và tên đi
hay đi và nên ê à à
số tự động tăng này
Ừ nó ba trà này 50 thôi
à à
à mà sẽ thêm một bảng là phố Đắt hay chỗ
nào em
khi mua đất hả
những chuyện lạ ID a Decade
và
22 điện lại
từ
khóa chính không nghe nào tự động tăng
cả à
anh nói nha khoa ngoại tình nhau nhé nối
Quá Ngoại tính sao đi bây giờ thì tôi
chị sẽ thử cốt cái đoạn này nếu mà làm
thì cũng bình thường là thêm
thêm thể loại cho sản phẩm thì sẽ nhà là
sự bây giờ khi mà for men shop thêm khổ
trước ở thêm nhà sản xuất nó ngon đây
tôi sẽ
web cơ bản
Army II
à à
bộ phim trước là nguyễnthanh thu rồi em
mình sẽ nhảy sang phim phục đắt đây ạ
10 ngày sẽ là à
ở quản lý sản phẩm thêm sản phẩm này khi
lần này tôi sẽ muốn là thêm thể loại nữa
được nữa đúng không ạ
Thể loại này
thì nếu như mà Hồi trước mình là mình sẽ
là
khi liệt kê toàn bộ các thể loại ở đây
như thế này là hai nay sẽ là
vi-rút thay này Paris à
mono file này à
à à
is2 ID này chẳng hạn thể loại ai đi lên
ok ok nè
Ừ thì có bạn sẽ thấy ở đây mình có thể
cho nó là dạng Monte bột là chọn được
nhiều cùng một lúc là sửa tôi cứ cho
trước hai thể loại đi nhá là kiểu là
điện thoạiphụ kiện lại
số
điện thoại này
phụ kiện
tai nạn này đó thì mếu hoàn toàn lệ chọn
hai cái cùng lúc hoặc chọn một cái Nếu
mà nếu mà chọn nhiều cái không Lúc ngoài
tôi nghĩ à ông nên để cho nó rặn mạnh
đầu tiên à vợ sẽ chữa cho ông mấy vụ cửa
làm cái cái bình thường nghe chưa đã sửa
khi mà ông chọn hai cái cùng lúc 2 chọn
một cái cùng lúc thôi để nó dạy ghét để
trong mấy ông thấy mình truyền lên cái
gì nhá á
Ừ hai cái cùng lúc này lên này em cũng
sẽ truyền lên ở đây đã chuyển lên nó
dạng mạnh thì nói thể truyền được hai
giá trị còn nếu mà ông để dạng và
một truyền đây một giá trị thì mấy ông
không chọn được ma túy bộ đấy nếu mà
chọn con tipo chọn nhiều cái không đốt
với ông phải để nó kiểu này để hiểu nó
dạng mặt chuyện ấy nhiều giá trị từ chợ
à
Ừ cái này lỗi code tự nhiên được kìa
mình đang dùng máy thấp post còn đây
mình đổi mới thấy ghét thì nó bị thế là
mình đổi lại hot nhá hãy ra sự với mình
Điền toàn bộ thông tin này cái này sẽ
lại
Ừ tôi lâu không cập nhật ảnh thông cảm
nhưng không thấy cái ảnh không cần thế
thôi
hình
ảnh đẹp nhất
trọn một lúc hai cái không Lúc đi kèm
thêm này
tôi sẽ gửi sang bên này
có thêm bản thân mình vẫn thêm vào trong
bảng cũ Đắt như bình thường rồi mình cần
phải lấy hai cái này nữa để mà in Shop ở
đâu Mình sẽ đi sữa ở trong bảo có đắt
hay này đúng không ạ Mình sẽ lấy mã của
hai cái thằng mà Bình thuyền lên sao
Insert vào trong bảng mua blog hay theo
cái board-id ở mình đã truyền đối ngoại
À hôm trước là tôi nhớ ở có bạn nó là có
hàm ý sốt rét ID của TP như có tôi thử
xem
Ừ cái này là
xe máy cao xem nào
ô ồ có hàng nào ngon phết nhỉ Thế thì đỡ
phải mất công salad lại đầu nhọn đỡ mất
con sẽ nhắc lại khá là ổn ở
À hôm hôm trước lạ hôm trước làm cái vụ
à order đấy mình phải mất công salad lại
đôi khi nó sẽ lỗi risus nhà lấy lại được
rất là ổn này
thì bây giờ mình sẽ thì mình sẽ xong này
thì mình sẽ
hay đi của khu đất đó ông ạ rồi đó thay
đi này
sẽ bằng mà có ai dai Asa đi
đỏ như thế này sau đó thì lấy con ếch à
Cái con ếch này
có
con ếch
nó sẽ lấy lại được cái mình ngồi nhìn sơ
không ạ sau đó mình sẽ Insert phát nữa
vào trong nhà mình sẽ có lấy
22 đi nhưng mà để ép nó xuống nhiều mà
chị sẽ là
hai ai đi này nó làm à trứng nhiều và
mình là mình cầm lấy là fuik này
H2 ID này
mình sẽ in shop vào trong bảng website
chỗ đó hai
mình sẽ truyền forestry vào anh không
đăng ký cột cũng được với Minh truyền
vào đúng hai cái
ID và
cái ID ngay
Ừ ok cho có vẻ ổn Đấy Thế thử nhé
khi chọn này
xin lỗi
à à thiếu thiếu chữ y tế toàn quên này
nó gợi ý nghĩa hơi say say
10 lỗi Ok thủ sản Thử lại xem nhé có pha
này
reset này
em không ra rồi nói gì có thể thức bốc
thai bị fractional nói chuyện là đúng
rồi nhỉ
ý của doc hai à quên quên quên quên với
lỗi tội lỗi tôi chia sẻ cái này
rồi tôi độ thôi lại phát nữa này
- flash này Đó lên rồi đúng không ạ Ok
thi thì cái này có bị ngược kia đó là
nếu mà nếu mà Mấy ông thấy là cái này là
mình phải nhập thể loại khó sẵn trước đã
đúng không ạ sau đó thì ở bên này Mình
chọn thì nó sẽ khác với việc là lúc này
thì các bạn muốn thêm ở một cái các bạn
lại ấn ở bên quản lý thể loạn đúng ạ thì
thì đấy là tác dụng của xoài nhất là nó
cho mình hoàn toàn để thêm mới một cái
hoặc trả chọn lại cái cũ rất là ôi sẽ đề
xuất lại cái cũ
ăn chay kiểu nha nó vẫn đề xuất cái cũ
nhưng hoàn toàn không thể nhập cái mới
của em tàu như này được đấy thì tôi
thích cái này ai hết này tha thứ
Ừ đấy kìa lại nó khuyên là nên sử dụng
thử hiện nay có thử thứ để tạo sự tại
thư viện này kết hợp với cả cái thay hết
mày để để đề xuất ra cái thời loạn cũ
cũng như là mình có hình nhập thể loại
mới khi vào nhập thể loại mới đồng nghĩa
việc mỳ Ý sốt và cảm
222 nữa đổ ngoạn nghĩa mình phải kiểm
tra mình sẽ về dùng à
anh và tôi sẽ can thiệp để nay bạn a-jax
luôn để mày Ông thấy à nó sẽ nhanh và
tiện như thế nào
em ở công ty áp dụng cái tròn này và tôi
nghĩ nhiều công ty là áp dụng kiểu này
tôi nói cái này ở trên phương diện mấy
ông về sau tôi sẽ tôi không biết làm
việc sưu tập quần áo lại không thôi
không chắc đâu nhá là về sau kiểu gì
Công cái cái gì kali và cái đã sát thì
kêu nó dậy là những cái nó cũng chưa
xong rồi và công ty ông Tuy là không là
không dùng cái này nhưng mà sẽ dùng cái
tương tự để mà làm một cái công việc gì
đó chỉ hướng sẽ thấy địa hình cũng như
hệ thống kê hôm trước tôi dậy nạn cái
biểu đồ đã tới công ty sẽ nào cũng có
nhiều không đi áp dụng không phải để thư
viện đấy thì cũng ở thư viện khác thì
mấy ông ấy biết cách mà làm thôi ông ạ
Đấy Tôi nghĩ là kiểu gì mày cũng nên
biết
cho tôi tôi thì dạy nếu mà nhiều bạn
từng đi học là để Trung tâm hay là học
nghề rồi mấy ông thấy tôi dậy được ra
còn cũng tương đối khá thực tế và còn
rút gọn rồi
anh không ạ tôi Tôi nghĩ là tôi dậy mà
ông còn rút gọn rồi đấy Nhiều không
Nhiều trung tâm dậy dài dòng Lê hay lắm
thế tôi khẳng định đúng thế thôi tâm dạy
ở đấy mà Linh kiểu dạy dài dòng không
không đi đúng không giải quyết được cụ
thể một cái bài toán đó tôi đang dạy khá
rút gọn rồi
có ai thì thường ở có cái thư mục đích
Xuân Này này nếu quan tâm này thì mày
không quan tâm trong này nó thứ viện mà
nó thì ông chen vào này tôi sẽ dạy này
nó ra mấy ông đi mở trước đây nó có thư
viện nó thư mục vào đây thì mới không
giải nén tránh việc làm ấy cũng sẽ lấy
một phát màu ra một đống phải
Ừ ăn sắc là một cái Hàn của trong di
ra bản chất nó là ít rồi là kiểu một
phương thức để gọi lên một cái file khác
cái gì gió để một đẩy thông tin lên hai
lấy thông tin về
khái niệm nói thế
Ừ cái này nói cho đến hơi bị bằng nhạc
tớ nghĩa là cách tốt nhất của tôi tôi
Tống sư cái này vào trong đây này đi
Anh Tạm thời như này ngày âm chưa Chị có
cho mày áp dụng thì đơn giản đi
ờ ờ
vậy tôi sẽ phải chèn file đúng ạ Cho nên
phải ở bên à phòng Minh suốt ngày này
phải xử lý đâu được sửa lại hết cái này
thôi không Tôi không dùng ai nữa
nó sẽ như thế nào
ông cố tôi vẫn có thể như thế nhá cốt ở
bên phố xét này tôi vẫn sẽ giữ nguyên ở
cho bé uống thấy nó có thể làm theo cách
kiểu như thế nào Tôi cần chèn thêm cái
đầu tiên xét đúng không ạ là Linh này
nhảy lên cái thư mục
ở nhà với thư mục này
khi copy lên nè
ạ
sau đó thì đến à this
sau đó đi đến à
Ừ nếu không dùng Angola rất thứ thứ
Ê mày không có thể ở chèn thêm cái Min
cho nó nhẹ được
sau
đó chuyển cái này và chèn thêm cái
Swift nữa a square Tôi từng nói Tao muốn
xuống dưới không ạ Chris này
hãy độ xe
Ừ Xem thế mà này
ở
cái chỗ có gj đó nhé
Ê
mấy ông Nguyễn Thị truyền thêm lấy áo
giáp cũng được không biết nhưng mà tôi
Tôi chưa làm vụ án dắt tôi sẽ dùng thay
hết rồi đây
có ai hết đấy để đề xuất Tìm kiếm cái gì
đó
từ khóa ôn
cái này Download mình ngoài đó là cái
phần mềm đọc
em chán hẳn SX ý
ừ ừ
a
Script này
nếu thể chèn thêm thấy bị được Tôi tôi
cứ chen em rồi nha À
Em về quê đi
Tôi nhớ à bên
ở bên wi-fi đấy có rồi
ở đây à
bình
thường mà easy clean tràn trước mọi mấy
cái hạn mà giờ thư viện kia trạng lỗi gì
và đương nhiên đoạn này vẫn thế nhé Bây
giờ mình sẽ áp dụng cốt như nay ờ
anh ở đây nếu mà gọi đôla Chắc là nó
phải cần thêm vào giấy
JP Morgan mà nó Con này xem tivi không
biết nó có tích hợp sẵn chưa Thôi rồi đi
này
anh ấy sẽ có à
à à
Ừ cái này tớ sẽ đặt hãy đi Nó bây giờ nó
là input đấy nó là input lại không ở tốc
độ đây phút nhé in tốt này
thay là tách đi
ạ sau đó đi nghỉ cho dì Năm thay thế cho
mình thôi cũng thay được không muốn dọn
nữa sợ ai đi này tôi xóa luôn cả cách
này đi tí rồi sẽ lấy nó bằng file hết
đấy dùng dùng rác gọn lên để lấy dữ liệu
về
Thái hết tính sau
ô
tô tại Nha Trang
Ai có nhà à
Ừ cái tôi từng bị khó chịu nó nhưng mà
tôi làm nên tao thì nó nhảy vào đây để
phải nhăn nhăn nó kiểu
vì vente fan của nó khi enter
khi chờ đợi tí nhá Ừ
Ừ bye bye thay hết để mà gọi lên lấy dữ
liệu về này à
Em hãy đi nó ạ à
có thể loại không ạ
Hay đi
thì
mình sẽ gọi lên lấy dữ liệu về
Ừ
Cái quan trọng là không chỉ gọi lên lấy
dữ liệu về nỗi nhớ là có thể đầy để giữ
lên để mà mình khi mà thêm muốn cái gì
sẽ
xe đẩy dữ liệu lên như thế này
xe tải về app này khi ông thêm một cái
gì đó thì ông sẽ
à à
anh rủ em nếu mà cái này là lưu lại
Ừ đợi tí nhé
primo Focus input
I even
bộ phim ma cái này Thêm này sẽ nhờ ai
còn cái này chưa lấy nguồn nó này Ok lấy
nguồn này
à à
em lấy nguồn này kìa
sẽ gọi đến Feiya
chờ đợi tôi một tí nhé Anh sẽ gọi đến
cái file à
shop đi rất hay trên Facebook về
chứ không phải search mà nice 2.tp ê
chị sẽ tạo ra file này á
a
startup and my này sẽ là ờ cái nồi cơ sở
Lý hậu sau đó đi
khi con nít này
này à
Ừ thôi
bị sốt cái qua trả về không Đây con ếch
này à
à à
em lấy cái này về
Đợi tôi một tí nhé
Ừ cái này thì ra là cách viết tắt khác
của Eric đấy à
anh nói viết nha à
chị sẽ biết thì cả address ngày cho mấy
ông thấy quen đi à
từ ngày dạng led mà trở về mình nên trở
về rạng dư sinh này
tao chuyển lên không truyền lên gì này
à à
chung kết quả trở về à
khi con à
Ừ
tôi không biết kẹp cái nãy giờ tôi đang
không biết là không biết thằng này thay
hết này cần trả về nó như thế nào để tôi
tự đọc ví dụ nó xem đã
à à
ừ ừ
cho nên em suốt anh không
Anh bận tí nhé
à à
bộ remote data này được rồi
ừ ừ
khi thời tiết thay inspec hàng ngày lên
xe mệt Nó trả về dữ liệu như nào mà mình
Hình dung là được là cần trả về cái gì
mà
à à
a a
remote mà nhé
ê ê xót xa
về này
Vì sao về là
ở
nhà thờ cha nhé
a a
thị zalo
ờ ờ
chú
bê này
thì nó sẽ gọi lên kiểu như thế này
Uh cho nó sẽ Cậu bị ra
Anh và Lulu
ở đia kia để mình in thêm trong cái A
e-blue này
Ừ ok là những cái từ những cái từ từ
kiểu cách ra bưởi những cách thì phải
đúng
ở những để kiếm
à à
ô
tô km cách cách nhau bởi phím cách này
chị sẽ cách ra bởi thoại nó dùng kiểu để
mà tìm kiếm à à
anh vào sự lưu Chắc nó lưu cách mạng cho
mình để tôi trả lại cho búp bê thì nó sẽ
không họ sẽ không gọi lên lần nữa
Ừ Ok có mẹ cách mạng khá hay thay vì
mình thì bị ra hết luôn mình sẽ truyền
lên cái gì nó BTC xin cái gì
I read me reason thương mại đấy
Ô hay Nói dùng hơi lạ của điện thoại
đang dùng mà
I live Alone à à
Hôm nay anh bị level u
I Swear
Ừ thôi chẳng hiểu cái này lắm
Họ đến thằng này
à à
chờ đợi thông một tí nhá
cả hai có ví dụ hơi hơi Nhung
Ừ tôi lên hạng trang tiết hấp của nó để
thử xem cái file này đi à
à à
ừ ừ
31 data
31.1 alo
Có phải chị nhắn này thôi à
em yêu nhé
ừ ừ
à À đây đây không không không Nó gọi bếp
đi chợ chứ này còn dưới này nó gọi thằng
bé Pixel này
anh bảo sao tự nhiên không thấy thằng bé
đi chơi ở đâu ngày mai đi chơi gọi trên
này nó truyền lên kiểu dạng này
em nói chuyện anh kẹo các thứ thứ tôi
tôi không bảo tôi sẽ không dùng cái này
phải dùng á giáp bình thường nữa bạn dễ
hình dung
ở nhà lọc được Analog được cách này bảo
sao
I Swear
Ừ quan trọng không biết thằng này nó trả
về cái gì Thôi tôi Tôi không biết hai
trở về đi để tôi thử nhé Cứ thử đã
ờ ờ
Ừ biết rồi tên được thằng resort ở đây
không được get ơn ở đây nó Peter nở
trong phương trình này theo Reuters ở
đây hơi hơi khó chịu
chứ tấn giờ này không được nhưng không
được
à à
xe ô tô chưa dùng tôi tôi chưa Làm cái
này lắm Mình chưa Tôi dùng hẳn cái này
Anh đang tôi sẽ dùng hạn cái này đi
không dùng lá sắc nữa đúng hạn cái này
đi xem sao nha à
à à anh đã không khác gì nhau lắm đâu ạ
à à à à
a.quy vắng phần trăm kg à
Ừ cái này Tại trước phải trước cái gì đó
mình không cần phải trước cho nó thế
mình đây mình có thể tìm kiếm theo cái
này
à à
ở nhà đây sẽ lấy cái này thì ra không
biết nên nêm này cho là cái input mình
đã
anh gọi tí nhé
à à
an apple
liên kết thư viện này không biết là tôi
cho em có phải thư viện nào chưa
à à
xã hội chưa biết tôi tôi chưa dùng thư
viện này rồi đấy nó sẽ dụng đây tôi cùng
mò cùng mấy ông thôi
có thể dùng nhé Để sẽ làm được nhé
bộ phim odetta phát lookup mẹ ngon
ừ ừ
à à
anh ạ
Ừ hình như có sẵn gì vậy mà không rõ đâu
nhé
à à
anh không vào lỗi thằng này nó hình như
nó vẫn chạy được
Vì sao tống vào trong đây đi xem
à à
Ồ thông báo lỗi gì đó lại nhỉ
see more money Speed
anh Alo ạ
Ừ quan trọng của tôi thấy nó không gọi
đến hàng à
Ê Thằng khoai kia à
con đường mình gõ cái này nó phải tìm
kiếm này
à mà thế à
Ừ có gì mà xài rồi
Xin chào tạm biệt nhà yêu nhiều quá
nhiều quá
a basic này
một bó hoa BD
em xem cái này rồi
chị
thay had played ô tô rồi bỏ qua
A gọi roasted đi làm chưa mình có xả
stress ở đây gọi logo bỏ qua khi Fix là
gọi trước
đi qua remote này mai mốt là sẽ
A gọi theo đúng kiểu ngay
ông Lê Hồ đồ crestec à
A Gọi thằng ngày mai mốt thì sẽ gọi
Google gọi đến cái
xe Vision
thế này
em thấy cái quay đi vào trong nhà dưới
xuân này à
A gọi đến file này sẽ lỗi không không
không tối được
ngoài cả
à à
Anh nói thằng này remote
có ai hết a đây hay hết chuyển đổi Xin
lỗi Xin lỗi
a
higher hash 0,8 input
à à
Ê thằng này kết hợp tác input điều gì
nhỉ Ừ đợi tí nhé
ở hai thái hết riêng hỏi tay in bút màu
xanh vừa rồi không được nhưng mà kết hợp
cả hai gì nữa
Ừ nó hơi khó hiểu đấy
Ê mày chắc là nó phải hỗ trợ cả tao
iPhone vào để chọn nhiều cái cốc chứ
à à
anh làm sao kiểu gì tội sẽ ngồi mò cũng
các bạn thôi những tấm hình tao
Wifi hết này ra đường này không nghe
được
à à
Ừ nó nó gọi lên tìm kiếm này
ờ ờ
sau đó sẽ in là gợi ý ở đây
à à
Lê Minh thử làm trước việc là inec gợi ý
các thợ số nào tôi thử kết hợp với tay
mu sau nói chuyện à
à à
a nay có sẵn dữ liệu này
ta
đổ nó có mạng đi à
Ừ
mai tôi muốn chạy về
và lu
con gà không cần mình mình quý ở bên này
nêm
cho nên là được
Âm Nhạc
cho nên này
nó đang làm
nên nó được
à à
ờ ờ
Ừ cái này chả với qua tôi muốn in ra
toàn bộ Kết quả này biến nó thành mảng
sách Android
Xin chào khách lần lượt
Anh nhớ là không có cái hàng khác nữa mà
lần thôi tôi chưa biết có làm khác Lấy
cái này không nhá
Không người mình phải làm cái cậu nông
dân nhiều ngay
Vietsub này
lại phải truyền vào tháng này bạn ạ Ừ
cho qua vào trong tháng ngày như này
in Android I
Ừ nó như này
ở trọ này
đẹp lắm nhỉ
ở
bảng sau đó mình đưa chạy có cái tìm
kiếm bằng đô la hét
à à
The Face Shop hình nhọn giống đẩy phối
kẻ thôi phải cá shop hay fake ở đây động
thế vợ Việt từng thẳng tuần hoàn mình
anh Năm muốn có một cái Hàn để lấy luôn
toàn bộ dữ liệu ra cùng lúc
Ừ tao lấy toàn bộ dữ liệu ra cho mình
chỉ cần EXO cái mạng đấy xong ấy
ờ ờ
đăng ký nha Thì mình sẽ tìm kiếm que
nêm
like phần trăm phần trăm đúng không ạ
đôla quay ở đây truyền Đây là quy mà để
sẽ được quy IQ và cha này
anh không cần tay lại
à à
xin lỗi em ạ
anh hứa chấm Face I
khi
quen tải lại trang không tỏ ra không
muốn tải lại đó gì có đồ này ngon đúng
không
Ê
Thằng này vừa nãy giờ nó có lưu lại cách
hai cái gì đó sẽ khiến cho không cần lại
không cần cơm bữa ăn gõ gì đó nó như này
à
à à
Ừ Ok thì bây giờ mình sẽ làm là mình sẽ
kết hợp với tác in bút này nữa không ạ
anh cứ sợ
sẽ có ngày qua chưa dùng đâu chịu
Ừ cái này sẽ lacosa này ngon
chứ không phải input nữa sẽ lấy caption
I Turn off cho nó hợp lý hơn để chọn
nhiều tròn cùng lúc nghe vẫn để nên tan
phút được
ở đây plothole đây Ok Ok
em hết đây đó tôi sẽ có cái này về là
xong đi Mệt ghê
à à
10 sao sở lại nhé
xin lỗi tội lỗi thôi
à à
A one-time hiểu mình chưa từng động vào
chính sinh viên mình từng mỏi vụ đấy rồi
nó cũng làm để mà làm quan sát bóp
à à
a Google like
Ừ thì vừa rồi mình nghĩ mình nên dùng mà
remote refix
bắt chước thằng vừa rồi mình là người
mốt ở đây hay bị fake
chị
xem quay cả các thứ thử đã bắt chước
phải vừa rồi thôi ở đây hoài cảm này để
mà tìm kiếm đổi cái này Thành à
ờ ờ list ID hoặc xơ Hay bây giờ hợp và
rất hay hơn về vấn đề tìm kiếm rồi
quy bằng này
anh hai đi tìm kiếm này này ra để được
cha là cái Elise này để gọi nó
rồi Đây là thay nha
chuyến Thay vào trong này
có biết cái này thì luôn kệ đi và lưu ký
alo đi chứ em đi này nên không biết nên
bỏ qua
cho nên nêm Ok Ok Thôi nha Được pháo năm
nay này
anh không lừa đấy không được đâu À đấy
ra luôn này Cái này bị lỗi phải giao
diện thì phải tôi chẳng nhớ do giao diện
tôi cạn
ô tô chèn đúng file giao diện không Cái
lỗi giao diện
ở hà thiếu Wechat nhỉ
chú ý nghĩa thì WeChat
à à
Ừ tôi conduce em sẽ cố tôi biết đó thiếu
chép này
Xin lỗi tôi bà xã không ra
Anh thèm lắm bút sáp Thế
Hoàng cứ bắt chước nó nó chèn ngay dưới
đi
à à
bố mẹ vợ xin lỗi enter để mình mình chưa
bắt trạng thái là yên tâm rồi nó sẽ sao
a dislike à Rồi rồi đi spiky Ừ Ok Mai kỳ
lên Ê mày nghỉ đi à
Vì sao đây để mục
Nike và Rookie
chế độ xem lại nhé
chị
Thu Zalo đấy
có ai hết
cho nên
anh đăng Ki
con cá mình phải lấy ra lụa tí nhé input
à à
ừ ừ
ở đây ông ấy đang in phút ấy cậu bao lâu
rồi
Ừ thôi không thích thế tôi thích à
à à
Ồ tôi thích mình input được cậu là ai đi
à Mình hiển thị ra là nêm cho mình Mình
lưu lại là lưu lại đi
Ừ
để tôi thử đây đội lên thì các bạn sẽ
thấy da
à à
số điện thoại thì đúng đúng nhưng mà khi
mình đẩy lên đây Bây giờ mình sẽ đẩy lên
nó là điện thoại hẳn luôn Thực ra thế
cũng tốt như này đã tự thưởng thêm Này
ông sẽ thấy là đẩy luôn cả điện thoại
lên thế này không ạ Thế không không
không không nên mình đẩy lên là để lên
kiểu đi thôi lưu lại trong này là input
thì nó là bị ai lưu lại nó là ai đi hợp
lý hơn hiển thị ra là nó là nêm nóng
lạnh nhưng mà
họ đậu xanh nha
ờ ờ
a Deep input
Ừ cái dipslide hay bị ẩn rồi mà rõ ra
khi truyền vào Thằng này nó sẽ lưu lại
loại khác
anh làm cách nào bây giờ
I
dislike I
thế nào để thử nhé
anh
khóc chắc chắn có một nêm này
Em bấm vào này nó ra kiểu Nga
thì hơi khó chịu đấy Cái này hơi khó
chịu
2000 nó ẩn đi thôi Không phải mình không
lấy được vợ lum các thứ thứ mà là mình
cần khi chọn xong ấy thì mình cần lưu
lại ở đây Mình sẽ lưu lại là ID
hợp lý hơn
Ừ để tôi cái gì cũng phải cắn Hiệp Vào
khi mà thêm một cái mà rồi để tôi sẽ can
thiệp vào
à à
ừ ừ
em thử xem Biết đâu được à
à à
em không có về không vội ở
hai iPhone Zalo à
à à
nhà báo sao à
bà con thôn kia này
i fell out optical
input ngồi trong phim tốt để có hình
nhập thoải mái cài thử khác Này
có này
lê thê haswell này
Em gọi đi này mua orifice à à
ừ ừ
I tell you
ở những cái được
ừ ừ
mà chả được
à à
- filestream
ừ ừ
em
bị lỗi làm sao á
à à
à Tôi nghĩ là cái này nó đang vấn đề là
từ thằng thay hết mẹ xem thai hết thôi
dislike này
à à
em
xóa hết đi Hiện Xem chạy được
à à
xin lỗi loạn expired
a name and displays
Ừ đợi thì nhớ về đội tuyển Nga
ở Sóc Sơn
Ê thằng này có phải ở kết hợp
Ừ Chắc không được rồi
anh khó chịu nhờ
Ừ cái lưu lại kiểu như thế này cả đi lại
chọn ngay nó không
anh không được Có lắm
ý nghĩa không được
ừ ừ ở
ngọn Remi này lên này
này à
à à
ai mà chẳng biết cái này nó đi cho xóa
thử đi nhé
anh vẫn được mà
a xuộc truyền lên gọi vào gọi và
em có thể nhập linh tinh à
Em đừng có phải được
còn enter mình ạ Mình đã bắt sự kiện
enter mình xăm ít mình phải bỏ về sự
kiện đấy đi bằng à Có gì nhiều cách để
một sự kiện này đi
các bạn hãy ti kia
ghép cây đào ấy
khi mà trong for này chẳng lại on
kỳ đào ghi áp gì đó
On key press thì phải crack ở cho cả hai
ingress
Và mình sẽ nhớ mãi ít even trầm khi Cốt
e
Băng Băng
lại đi 13 thì mình sẽ đi Vân chấm
preventdefault ngay hệ không cho nó sắp
mi form một cách thử nha à
khi
mở heo
được không ạ ạ
à à
Ừ thôi Bây giờ mình có thể chơi theo
kiểu Ok bây giờ là
à mình mình cứ thử đẩy cái này lên và
mình sẽ lấy ID dựa trên cái cũng được
hơi khó chịu thế dẫn mình sẽ truyền cái
này lên bây giờ mình sẽ truyền đây là
dạng nêm với mình à Thế nên sẽ thì thay
này mình lên là thứ nhất là mình sẽ cho
nó là unique cái lên này hợp lý hơn này
trợ cho uống đi cái nơi mà
ạ
sau đó đi khi mình nhìn sốt lên bây giờ
mình là sự mình ăn thêm mẹ ạ thì mình sẽ
à mình sẽ kiểm tra từng cái mê mải một
sẽ rồi tha lại mình đổi tên là thai nên
được
nó xuống nhiều đi
ở bên như thế phải sửa lại Bữa nay hai
ngày hai đêm này Vào đây mình sẽ là hai
lên đây là hai nơi này mình sẽ kiểm tra
và chép Wow selects
sao for ta it was named bằng
hai lên này
ờ ờ
anh cao đi cho nó dễ hơn
rồi kết quả Trở Về
Ừ cái nè Có phải rất dài Sao thế Sao
rosler đoạn này hay 300 thôi à
anh
sex bằng
xe máy kéo J5 pro 075 pro
fire Vietsub
các bạn cốt cao sao
sau đó thì ít Đó là trách bằng bằng
không sẽ là không có thì mình sẽ Insert
bị sẽ vậy in Fisher và trước Insert into
thai
nên và lưu
nên hay mềm này à
ạ
sau đó mình sẽ lấy gái isis ID
Có
ai đi này
Còn nếu không thì à Nếu thế thì không
phải to sao tôi lấy hết
ở ngay đi trả về này thấy thằng đầu tiên
này
à à
Vì thế tôi kiểm tra đây nếu mà
anh
đợi tôi tí nhé
Hay đi
thay
nhưng mà không có
à mà không có thằng này
Cho
mình xin xuất vào nó lấy thai đi Còn nếu
có thì mình sẽ lấy thai ID bằng hai cột
tại cột ID đó mình Insert rồi đây
Em thử nhá Tôi tạm tắt hay đi không phải
đi rất nhiều mà không vẫn vẫn phải có gì
xuất
cơ cấu trúc thủy thủ sao Bin
hôm
nay nhớ bị lỗi này với tôi cho ở đâu Ở
đây đây đây cho cái này toàn bộ là input
này mất rồi à
Ừ ok này
lịch sử Nga đã chọn anh tivi với ông già
chị hỏng vụ cho này như vậy
U50 này
đó đây mình sẽ cho một cái có sẵn rồi
lúc cái chưa có đi
như này
cơ sở mẹ thêm lỗi
đó là quy đổi mới thoát nó ra nhà Push
ax
ở Nhật Bản
à à
Ừ
cái này còn lập trùng rất tiện mày không
khéo Nếu mà tốt cho sự nhập lại giống
thì nó sẽ quẹo xóa đi anh thêm này
10 lỗi không lỗi chưa chắc là chạy được
mình cứ thử xem đã xem đầu tiên ở trong
bảng 2 mình đã hiển thị ra
khi đó ở đây là à Rồi rồi rồi nghĩa là
mình truyền lên mà mình truyền lên dạng
kiểu Dạ không Mình mình phải biến nó
thành nhà tiên nó thành kiểu cách nhau
bởi dấu phẩy đúng không thấy cách nhau
bởi dấu phẩy đã biến nó thành mạng đã
đầu tiên tôi sẽ đổ ở đây à bây giờ nó sẽ
không có lành mạnh nữa rồi
hoặc là hoặc là để rủ nhé Để thử ờ ờ
mày không nghĩ kỹ chưa Này Monte bồ
select multiple
Ừ để để tôi thử dùng cái xe lách này
không biết được có dụng cho cái này
không nhé
anh không như thay ốp trần nhà
hỗ trợ thì tôi cứ thủ cách này trước làm
xong nốt cái này đã tính tiếp nhé Cái
này Tôi hẹn dùng pro này ta sẽ cắt nó
thành mạng
chỉ cách nhau bởi dấu phẩy này sẽ như
thế này là được nên tự thử nhưng sợ lại
không xem
à à
AE nhập im Grow pro
a stroman
à
À quên người quên tôi tôi truyền bên này
bị nhầm Tại lại tra mã Vừa rồi tôi
chuyển hay lên rồi mà đưa nó mới là chỗ
này gọi lại con nữa nha
à à
Ông Ngoại trưởng à mà cách nhau bởi dấu
phẩy này ra một phát nói giỡn một đống
ok
à à
Ừ thôi à Thế mày không báo lỗi em nha
chú chó mày không phải không điện thoại
có rồi nó sẽ không đi suốt nó sẽ chỉ
xuất hai cái này thôi ngon chưa được đấy
for high nhé
cho nó lên này là sự đâu có xóa hạn đi
mày Ông bảo tôi biết nha
ô tô tải lại cái này thì có thai nó phải
lên
ở đó và thay thì vì ai rồi Anh thấy là
nó không đi sơn nữa Gửi chưa Ok chưa
ngon rồi đấy ông ạ tổn hơi nhiều thời
gian nhưng mà Mấy ông cũng sẽ hiểu hơn
là việc à Thằng này nó sẽ kết hợp nhiều
yếu tố như nha cả mà nó cứ
tiếp theo tôi thử ở đổi thành salad
multipulse mà có biến thứ tôi vẫn mong
muốn mà tôi muốn lấy được ID của cái hai
này chứ không phải đã nên do ngồi kiểm
tra thêm một phát nữa ở trong bê như thế
này chạy vòng lặp kiểu như này nó không
hay lắm Tôi từng nói rồi ạ mấy vòng lặp
ngày không hay lắm thì à Thế thử nhé
ở đội nón hình xe rack-mountable Việt
Nam
ai
biết đâu được
à à
Ừ
thôi nó thành đạt ghét à
à à
cho nên vẫn điện thoại mất rồi
anh ngắm tí bộ hàng em ạ
anh alo chi
nó khóc Nó vẫn thấy ông ạ lừa
thôi này thấy mình sẽ này áp dụng mà làm
Phải cho nông dân tí lại với một kiểm
tra lại nêm như thế này sao nhiêu phút
lên còn nếu không ấy thì đó có khách
khác thì tôi đang nghĩ
nó là bởi ông ngồi mò thêm mấy cái even
của nó này là khi mà áp khi mà thêm vào
Ý chia mình em tôi để thêm báo ấy thì
bản chất đó lưu lại trong cái input khác
một Inbox để hai đơn nữa được và mình
lấy theo input thấy nó hợp lý hơn thay
vì mình lại cái input này input này đón
còn êm Và thậm chứa các bạn thể in sót
trước khi mà không phải bên thường gặp
trên phố xanh Asus này thì mình nên chỉ
nên làm là cố sách in ra cho thằng phố
đắt còn những cái bảng khác giống như in
xơ và bạn thay Nhưng nó không đúng và
mình nên à mình nên bắt sự kiện là khi
mình thêm một cái thể loại mới khi mình
thêm kiểu nhà à
anh Bởi vì sao nhé bây giờ sự nhé tôi gõ
một đống Thế thì thể loại ngay đúng
không Nhưng nhỡ tôi không ẩn thêm thế
này thì toàn bộ những cái thể loại này
của tôi Tôi vừa ẩn ấy nó sẽ không được
thêm một trong bảng thay đổi ngoạn bởi
vì mình thêm như này thì cái phố đắt thì
cái này mới được chuyển lên để mà để mà
Insert vào trong bảng 2 Đông ạ nhỡ đâu
và tôi Ngập ngập như này tôi nghĩa Bây
giờ tôi chưa một resort lại vội thành ra
toàn bộ Thay màn lấy được cái gõ thì
cũng sẽ không bị rơi rớt nóng lạnh thì
mấy ông có thể làm bắt theo sự kiện ở
thằng này có đó là khi mình thêm một cái
gì đó thì mình có thể gọi Isaac lên
trước thì Bị nhân xơ và trong bảng 2 này
trước để mà lúc mà lấy này nó sẽ luôn có
giá trị mình không cần phải reset lại
không phải chạy vào vậy sát ngay chứ
không tốt đấy thì ạ
ở đây là một cách và thật cao Tôi nghĩ
là kiểu gì nó cũng sẽ có cách mắt là nó
bắt sự kiện và khi mà thêm lại đi đó chứ
nó sẽ truyền hay đi vào trong 10 phút mà
mình sẽ lấy cái một ngày inbox khác ở
đây này một input hay đơn ở đây à
hay hai đơn này không ạ sau đó mình sẽ
nêm thực sự là thay ID nhà này và nó
dạng mai sau mình sẽ cũng mỗi lần thêm
vào trong này bạn chắc là mình sẽ bắt sự
kiện thì mình thêm cái ID của cái thằng
này Vào trong vào trong đây
nghĩa là mình hiển thị ra cho người dùng
thế thôi nên sẽ là mình không quan tâm
mình thích thì mình để đi xây bồ cũng
được để đi xe bồ nha cha vẫn được đấy
vẫn vợ vẫn nhập được mà Không không
đường này
khá không nhưng thật ra không quan trọng
này nữa mình bỏ nêm cái thằng này đi
cũng được mà nó sẽ không trở lên thôi
nghe nhập vui cùng bạn được yêu niềm vui
Đấy mình không chưa lên họ mình chưa Lê
Ừ chiều lên ngày nay xe mình thêm cái gì
trong này mình lấy IDM ngay đây với anh
này Đấy nó sẽ hợp lý hơn đấy chị ạ ngày
không hiểu Có Vay Có chế như thế nhưng
tôi nãy giờ chị nói qua thôi Bây giờ tôi
sẽ nhảy sang cái khác không cả bộ ông
Mai chị nói Mỗi cái đấy buồn lẫn cả tiền
thế
Vì sao nãy giờ ngồi chữa cốt một lúc
thấy hiệu người xem giao hẳn 28 người Ok
thì
cho con cái vụ chọn thành phố này nữa cơ
trở thành phố khá phức tạp này
ở thành phố này thời gian là mấy ông sẽ
phải trả thêm cái á
không ra thói quen tôi ít người rồi sinh
viên câu lạc bộ lập trình của tôi từng
dậy chỉ có ba người thôi tôi vẫn dậy
nhưng chưa ạ
khi chọn thành phố anh như tôi từng nói
khi thấp
hoặc Chắc là ta ta đi ta reason này
thành phố
có đấy
em có này
thì có mà nó hết ở đây nè
Hồ Văn Thiện
anh phải hỏi rất lớn
có phải không Cho tôi cho mày ông xem
qua nó lớn kinh khủng đâu luôn
ông sẽ phải mắc tinh người này vì vậy mà
khi mà chọn cái gì đó thì nó sẽ đề xuất
cái cái tương tự
Ừ nhưng mà cho bây giờ không đủ thời
gian để mà
Ừ nếu mà ngồi làm cái gì Xuân Này Tôi
nghĩ là Cứ tẩm kệ đi à
Mẹ tôi
nếu mấy ông thực sự muốn làm thì tôi sẽ
cho sẽ nói sau tôi sẽ nói qua về notify
đã
Xin mời bia bên ngoài cũng không cần
phải gọi đến bên thứ ba phức tạp làm gì
cả Bởi vì a gọi sang bên 13.000 sẽ bị
đau hơn là việc là nó loạt sẵn trên
chính máy của mình không ạ
và xử lý có thể mấy ông muốn loại bỏ
quận huyện đó Vân Vân
thằng bên thứ ba đấy cũng hỗ trợ vụ đấy
ở tại soạn và Nói chung thằng đứng thứ
ba là mình sẽ phụ thuộc vào nó được Kiểu
thận chỉ mất phí hay là nó mà người
thỉnh thoảng treo chết thì cái gì đó thì
bị chết ở đấy thì ông kia đang nói nghỉ
Tết thì tội đang định hỏi rõ đó Thật ra
tôi bảo mi ông là thứ bảy mình sẽ nghỉ
Tết nhưng mà Thứ năm bữa thứ năm các bạn
Tôi vừa gạt kèo làm tất nhiên ra là tôi
thì tôi bảo gọi cánh phải gần nửa năm mà
tôi ra đường em trong một tháng gia đình
ít cực ít cực nhưng mà
các bạn đã kể Tất nhiên thằng nãy mình
nhé Thôi chả Thứ 5 này mình tạm cũng
nghỉ Hôm nay sẽ bộ livestream mà
chú chim cuối năm ông ạ
khoa học 11 à thực ra có nhiều ông inbox
tôi là kiểu tết này em chẳng có cái gì
làm chẳng đi đâu cả nên em sẽ ngồi cốt
đồn thâu thâu Tết tôi được ra Dũng sẽ
ngồi cốc thôi thôi Tết đấy thôi có làm
gì đâu Không có người để chơi của cho
cũng không có được đi chơi nên hình ra
là
U60 cốt mày ông có thắc mắc gì mày ông
Hoa làm với ông một có người có cùng
Ngày mai em có nhắn tin nữa tôi Anh em
cho mình sẽ ngồi cùng cốt mà nhau cho
vui
con để dậy ra tôi nghĩ à Không đi dậy
không đấy cũng bảo là livestream tâm sự
có được
Ừ ừ
được rồi sẽ ngồi chơi game này không mấy
ông thích chơi nhân phẩm không ạ
Ừ cái câu không người để chơi được ai
lấy cũng từ cái trang cái kênh đu đấy
trẻ có nói chung có nhiều video hay mà
ông xem thử
cũng bớt nhạt cũng nghĩ thế bước nhạc à
ờ ờ Ok tôi nói qua cái notify có bạn họ
nha nối file Tôi dùng thực ra là nó sẽ
có 2 kiểu thông báo một cái Suite nó rớt
một cái notified tôi thích dùng gửi
notified hơn
bởi vì a trải nghiệm và tốt hơn hãy tự
thử cho bé uống xanh bạn whittled thì
mình cũng sẽ dễ hình dung I
You are not the heart thông báo gì đó
đồng phát nhìn người dùng kiểu nhé hả Ừ
trong mỗi vẻ chuyển động trong vẻ hay
đấy Nhưng mặt nó không tốn diện tích quá
người dùng ở mất công click thứ thứ
nhưng mà Đấy những thông báo quan trọng
thì mới ra mấy thì kiểu ngay còn thường
mà tôi thích dùng cái này hơn
ờ ờ rồi bận rồi lại cậu ngày nó nhìn thị
ra như thế này mà nó tự động tát Thằng
Duy ra rất thường gặp có tự động tắt Đây
là thời gian hàng suy ra lớn này hợp với
việc là kiểu hiển thị ra một cái gì đó
để mà có phơi hay để nhập cái gì đó ở
trong ngoài hiển thị dung kịch thông báo
gì đó nó Plus mà nó ngoại nó thể hiện sự
nghiêm trọng hơn còn notify tôi thấy nó
nhẹ hơn cốt này các bạn thấy thời gian
nó rất đơn giản thôi gian chỉ cần như
gợi ý à Thứ viện thôi mình mới Ông thấy
cô đơn giản cục như thế này không chỉ
cần có copy cái này về lo chạy không ạ
Đấy cái ông chén thư viện về cách để
tránh bưu điện thì mới Ông thấy tôi thừa
rồi download về xong rồi yêu nó nóng ạ
chè nó ra là sau này thì thôi
Ừ cái có thể hết nhiều chị tùy biến ở
các sự hư cái notify mình thường anh
dùng ở đâu khi mà mình ấp lót xong cái
gì đó hoặc là dùng giống như vừa nãy bắt
thêm sự kiện này khi mà thêm một cái
input gì đó thì mình có thể thông báo
luôn ở đây là tao đã thêm Thể loại này
luôn cho mày rồi đấy đáng để mày lần sau
có thể dung cũng rất là hai ông ngoại mà
chọn cái gì đó thường là nó còn để cảnh
báo nữa mình nhập cái gì đó lỗi ở đây
thì một ông hiển thị lỗi đây hai ông
kiểu hình chị ra đây nữa cũng như cách
ngoại
ở Hà Nội có quả thằng boss nữa Ok nói
tôi Mình nhớ có sau này nữa
Cái này thì ra là
Ừ tôi thấy ở thành phố tôi thấy thì
không đẹp bằng hoa Wifi nhưng tôi thích
là cái hẹn này không thể không Nó có
hiển thị thời gian và gần nha Có thấy K2
lời chung nhà rất nhiều cái thư viện làm
bé uống thể tham khảo thường công ty
thôi thì đang dùng là notify
em được mấy bạn hỏi mấy bạn thì cứ hỏi
mọi thứ thôi Còn việc không phải việc
trả lời hay không là tùy mình mà là trả
lời được không
Ừ thì mấy tụi mình đó ngoại con là mình
sẽ luôn trả lời có thể ra không trả lời
ngay được rồi Mình đang bận gì đó vẫn
chơi bận à ngồi
đi Ba
ở Bệnh bận n thứ mà đôi khi ở quên Các
bạn cứ nhắn tin nhắn mình mình mình hơi
bị à Quỹ thời gian của mình có 24 giờ
nhưng tất cả bạn cho mình kiểu bị Hơi bị
tham tham công tiếc việc nên thế giờ là
một ngày mình làm như rứa mà mình cũng
hay quên Các bạn thấy
tầm quan trọng các bạn ý thức không hẳn
lại cao nhất đối với mình nhưng nói
chung là cũng có cái gì đó nhưng vẫn vì
không ai quan trọng nhất là sử sếp Bảo
bớt thì thôi nhưng mình hãy tiên cái bác
cái hơn
a b tôi làm công ty sợ cực miễn mạng
kiểu đưa có vấn đề gì đó bất toàn liên
quan đến nghìn đô sợ cực
May mà sẽ bị trừ lương phát nào nhưng mà
nói chung nhà tôi sẽ phải Ưu tiên những
công việc khác hơn nha các bạn nhắn tin
và thỉnh thoảng nhắc mình nếu mà xử thấy
mình à
chị đã xem hoặc là ở trả lời muộn thì
mấy ông có nhắn tin phát nữa thì trôi
không bị trôi đi ngắn hơn đấy giờ chắc
là tôi cho mấy ông xem quá Messenger rồi
Mẹ bầu cua online book online được trả
lời Mấy anh em yêu tim mình nắm giữ sinh
khoản vay trên bầu cua lại ở trên này và
mấy anh và anh đợi anh đã anh Đạt thành
cái cốt cái đấy hay phết nạt có nhiều
cái giữa hai chia sẻ Ông nhóm nhiều bài
2A
à à
Ừ anh ấy cũng tương lai chuyên nhạc Hồi
đấy tôi có livestream để mà
không biết được đây tôi kiểm tra xem con
không
Chắc là sẽ bị xóa mà hồi ấy Tôi nói
chung nhà xong rồi Còn lấy cả theo api
của thằng Facebook để mà lấy lấy cái
bình luận mấy ông bình luận trong
livestream hiển thị lên trang mới ra
dùng ra Swift làm điều đấy đùm lá rách
hư khá nặng nhưng khá hay
Xin Hãy ấn nhầm đăng bài lại chứ ạ
ờ ờ
A Goodbye Me
Vì vậy tôi
tặng đầu lắm rồi
em chọn từ
20182017 gì đấy
à à
ở
đây đây
à Hôm nay tôi dùng tôi có no lắm 2017 mà
nó nói chưa à
ở đấy không thấy cái mặt nghe
người ta tắt tiếng Không ăn bản quyền
ở
Huế có dùng thư viện thì định là đẹp lại
đây
một số người bình luận này số người đang
đợi
đã bình luận này thì trùng dại mà nhiều
nội dung bình luận nhìn bị là 20 cái này
tăng lượng tương tác cao cực nãy con thứ
hãy hỏi tôi là chính nhạc ngay xong rồi
mấy ông bình luận có thứ gì nó sẽ chỉ ra
đây
Em có ngồi đấy là Lưu tin chia sẻ rất
nhiều thứ hay nhận
đăng hơi nhiều cái nó không phải liên
quan công việc đi nữa cũng hay nhưng mà
thôi được ngoài công nghệ tí nhiều nữa
không có nhiều tài liệu nhiều nữa
em hẹn mấy ông muốn là mail cái
Vì vậy tôi làm
grab.api lấy thông tin về rồi về sau tôi
phải sửa lại vì hiển thị ra một cái bình
luận hơi lâu mới thấy ông thì thận 5.000
55 nghìn năm bình luận thành cửa sổ đợi
Lộc ngồi gõ cái không hiểu bao giờ mới
lên sóng
Em hãy hồi nãy không bị ăn mòn quyền
luôn Vì sao tự nhiên cái em bé không thể
có thấy mình quyền này phải 2 năm sau
thằng thuế gỗ rồi đánh bản quyền này của
tôi chứng tở thằng ai ai cũng ngồi quét
liên tục ghê vãi cả từ thứ
anh
nói chung là hồi đấy tôi mò facebook khá
nhiều và thời đại Facebook hỗ trợ khá
nhiều họ không cấm đoán các thứ sức kẻ
bản quyền cũng như bây giờ đấy thế nên
là mấy ông Thực ra là bây giờ mới tìm
hiểu Thực ra cũng hơi bị buồn thế ông ấy
ông bây giờ mới bắt đầu tìm hiểu
Facebook không biết ở nhiều ngày thứ hai
họ nó nhưng ngoài ra ngoài ra từ cái gọi
bây giờ lại có rất nhiều thư viện hay là
rất nhiều thứ khác với ông mò cũng đưa
tài liệu của mình không đọc thử Tôi
chẳng có gì để đọc được cứ phải mong mà
được thì tốt không thì thôi
Ừ thôi nói chung nhà bây giờ cho là cũng
muộn rồi ạ Hôm nay buổi cuối cho mình sẽ
bạn bạn thông báo lại để cho các bạn hết
không thứ năm lại hỏng Minh
tạm cái gì đó nha có mọi thắc mắc gì Các
bạn cứ tại bình luận thôi mình sẽ phải
táo nhé
Ừ cái này chắc là cũng tương đối trả lời
rồi muốn có chọn Thành Phố OK
ở army cái này chả mình sẽ chia sẻ sau
đi mấy cái này chưa sẽ sau đấy này nhá Ừ